[Music]
I had to put one on it's great cousins
but it's a really a window into the
process everybody works so hard
everybody prepares so thoroughly that
when mistakes happen they're funny
because it reminds everybody on set and
it's a very imperfect process there's
one from Winter Soldier we're in the
scene I have to push scarlet and when I
push her like a little bit of sound just
uncontrollably
you know squeaked out very soon I think
the rest of the day was kind of derailed
because we couldn't stop laughing that's
going on the outtakes
[Music]
I'm gonna do that again cuz that was
terrible I don't know if what my most
embarrassing blooper is I have a lot of
bloopers to think about time travel
he's always laughing where I'm not
supposed to I know there's awkward
dances that are floating around out
there those don't really embarrass me so
much is sickening so you want me to go
Jamie Foxx on this one Oh everybody put
on your sunglasses
denzel's coming out anthems should be
all a lot on them I have a gag reel
flying about 80 miles an hour just a big
chocolate missile I probably will not be
on the gag reel I again I doc I was very
steadfast and professional you want
Wesley Snipes at Denzel I don't want to
see the Wesley's then it's gonna be a
boring guy gross
that means that Hiddleston's on the gag
reel benadryl come a bit it's true
I'm going full cheeto on this take don't
give both these poor G know what Ben
Affleck or Keanu Reeves are you going
number two yeah it's hard to imagine a
car hitting you in the face would you
like to give me so much ten years of it
we love joke sunset I mean we like to
keep it very loose having fun is
invaluable
Robert Downey has made us laugh as hard
as anyone we can think of we are getting
the whole team aren't we oh my god well
any time perhaps around this time I'm
going to drop my guns and I'm gonna act
my ass off if there's ever a chance that
Favreau how far not happen to be within
100 miles of each other that always
works I say that the stand out nonsense
player lately has been hmmm
damn well be anything hold on there's a
fly
is that good
[Music]